asking
for okay so um our host um and um
basically searching um takes care of Pi
data um in in the sort of the Chicago
area and she put out a sort of a call
for speakers sometime last year and
asked if there's anybody who' be
interested to give a talk to the to the
community and uh you know that uh that
call for speakers relate through US
Chicago or CS department and uh I said
yeah I did something that's pretty
interesting and maybe useful to people
who work in the intersection of python
and data and pandas and uh that was last
year and then soing uh immediately
responded when I reached out and said
yeah sure we have some time in uh
October would you be interested and I'm
like yeah sure absolutely I didn't
realize she said October of
2023 so this meeting was scheduled a
full year in advance um and that was
before I um I was still a PhD student at
the University Chicago I graduated in
March and I'm now um uh teaching faculty
at the University of Chicago so I teach
uh Python and I teach uh databases I
teach a little bit of pandas as well to
people who are taking computer science
possibly people taking uh public policy
as well so long story short today was an
extremely busy day this was the first
thing that was scheduled last year but
then uh my teaching responsibilities as
well as a bunch of back-to-back meetings
meant that I had to make sure I you know
get to downtown from the hi Park Campus
and make sure that I'm here on time so
I'm glad that uh that kind of worked out
so for today's talk I want to talk about
a um uh sort of like an open source
project that I worked on during my PhD
um it's called fuzzy data and it's a
scalable workload generator that can be
used for testing um uh any sort of
workflow system that works with uh data
frames and this is work that I did uh
along with my uh
my previous my my adviser I guess when I
was a phc student Aaron Elmore um and
he's currently a co-instructor with me
for um teaching introductory python at
the University of
Chicago so without any further Ado let's
talk about what database benchmarks look
like right so the idea is databases are
super useful everybody's using them in
different types of
applications and the databases have been
around for many decades which means that
database benchmarking has also been
around for many decades right if you're
talking about database systems that are
basically relational database systems
are dbms's that use some kind of U
traditional query Engine with SQL um
benchmarks have existed since the 80s um
there's a uh long and storied history
with a lot of intrigue and a lot of
politics and lot of uh mudslinging when
it comes to database benchmarks uh um um
long story short uh Wisconsin used to be
one of the leader I mean it still is one
of the leaders in academic research and
databases uh and they released some
something called the Wisconsin Benchmark
in
1983 which was used to give an Apples to
Apples comparison between different
database systems um in in their initial
paper uh Oracle did not do very well in
this Benchmark um causing aot lot of
problems between Oracle and the
University of Wisconsin Larry Ellison
very famously um tried to uh sue the
University of Wisconsin because of this
Benchmark and um basically threatened to
never hire anybody who graduated from
that University back in the 80s but uh
as a result every academic database
paper that is uh has results uh
comparing um something with a commercial
system system now has something called
the divit clause which means they won't
name those database systems by name when
they publish in these uh academic
journals but anyway um so relational
systems have had this right for a while
and then the industry came uh together
uh in the transaction processing Council
or
TPC uh and then they said let's agree to
a set of benchmarks that we can all kind
of use to compare database systems
against each other so the transaction
processing Council or TPC has a fairly
standardized Benchmark for all of these
relational database systems and they
have many flavors or many variants of
benchmarks there's something used for um
relational traditional o oltp systems
transactional systems and then they have
something for uh columnar systems and uh
data integration and so on and so forth
right with the emergence of the cloud um
one thing that happened was the entire
nosql movement which meant that people
were moving away from relational
database systems in the interest of
scaling right so people wanted to move
away from the relational database
Paradigm they wanted to uh build simple
sort of like key value stores or
something that you could plug to a to a
website front end that allowed you to
very quickly get some information
provided some key they did not want to
use any sort of complex query semantics
like
SQL um work from Yahoo uh became the the
main benchmarking tool for cloud uh for
these kinds of systems the key Value
Store systems it's called the Yahoo
Cloud serving Benchmark or ycsb and it's
been standard since 2010 you can f you
can use this Benchmark to Benchmark any
sort of key Value Store from Cassandra
to hbas or um you know any sort of
product from these uh uh you know key
Value Store vendors right no SQL vendors
but there isn't really something good
for data frame systems and when I talk
about data frame systems I'm talking
about pandas right anywhere any sort of
system in which you're working with data
frames and not database tables um where
you might have sort of um
semi-structured data may possibly
multi-dimensional but there is some kind
of spreadsheet style ordering of the
data that you that you have so what
makes these data frames different from
uh relational database systems right so
data frames allow you to mix semantics
across sort of Rel ational spreadsheet
style operations you can uh represent
things like matrices or relational
tables or spreadsheet data into a data
frame object and it allows you to issue
queries that may you know usually
usually you can express them in SQL but
there's also these kinds of operations
that are not as easy to do in SQL like
pivots for example which are easy for
spreadsheets to do but in the process of
preparing data for machine learning
pipeline people find tools like pandas
to be much more useful to operate with
these um data
frames and the basic history of data
frames is you know it kind of started
From statistics the there was a special
purpose language called s that came out
in
1976 uh similar to relational tables but
they allowed for you know operations on
large
matrices um then the r programming
language became popular and was open S
basic took the semantics of s and data
frames uh came out in around 1993 um so
the S language was essentially open
sourced by R but the real moment for
data frames kind of came from um
computational finance and Wes mckin uh
who introduced the pandas project in
2008 so he liked the data frame
semantics in the art programming
language but he also wanted to bring in
the power of python to write sort of
custom pythonic code uh to operate on
these data frames so using uh numpy as a
backend um he basically developed the
pandas uh package which allowed you to
sort of use those R style semantics to
operate on uh to Define and operate data
frames in um in in Python right and then
you can see that you know that was kind
of the the sort of the moment where data
frames kind of exploded in popularity
and went beyond just people who are in
statistics right so machine learning
engineer and so on and so forth kind of
found a a neat language where they can
marry both sort of like the data frame
um um you know sort of mode of operation
right the data frame semantics but with
the power of this expanding Universe of
python projects you know most of which
actually come from you know basically
supported by num Focus right now from so
the the core uh you know numerical and
Scientific Python uh libraries that are
available number Pi CPI and so on uh and
the combination of all of this and the
fact that all of the data was
interoperable between all of these
libraries made pandas extremely popular
right so we have the the the Google
Trends graph something you would see in
a lot of these presentations talking
about how things are super popular but
what has happened recently is people are
trying to Crunch larger and larger data
sets on pandas and that because of the
way pandas was written using a numpy
backend there are scaling bottlenecks
that prevent pandas from being used
effectively in sort of these uh cluster
environments or um uh distributed uh
Computing environments where you may not
have a shared um memory available to
multiple processors and because of that
now we have a whole zoo of uh pandas um
or or data frame related projects that
try to scale pandas out into uh multiple
sort of distributed computing
environments right so if you had a
cluster you could try to process your
data using spark uh if you have a lot of
cores on your laptop maybe there's some
other engines execution engines that you
could use to try to scale your data
frame processing this is for millions of
uh uh you know database uh data frames
that have millions of rows or possibly
millions of columns right depending on
how things are
structured so
um and because this like performance
evaluation of data frame systems is not
something that we see to the caliber for
what we have with um traditional
relational database systems or key value
stores mostly what you're going to
depend on is anecdotal evidence from
people who use these systems right so
someone might tell you hey use U you
know modin or use Ponder data or use
spark and if you have a job that
requires you to process millions of uh
rows in a data frame you'll get x amount
ount of speed up if you throw it into
the system right so mostly we just have
to go by these um uh vendors by their on
their word that you know we we've wrote
a high performance query engine it's
much faster than pandas and it'll it'll
help you out right so usually if you
visit sort of so modin for those of you
who don't know is a dropin replacement
for pandas that is supposed to use an
execution engine like Ray or dask in the
back end and automatically speed up
anything that you were trying to run on
pandas so you could instead of saying
import pandas as PD in the top of your
Python program you can say import mod
than. pandas as PD and then you can sort
of just reuse your entire Python program
without by just changing One Import so
that's what they're well that's what the
modin project um is essentially selling
and then what they kind of say is
because they have a a distributed
execution engine beneath uh common uh
data frame operations like you know read
CSP or checking if a certain dat data
frame is null or if you want to apply a
map operation to everything in a data
frame you'll get x amount of speed up
right um but in reality if you kind of
visit the modern issue page on GitHub
you're going to see a lot of people
saying hey I was sold this promise that
if I just replace one line I will get an
immediate speed up the truth is you know
not all operations are paralyzed there
are operations that are that will uh
take time and then you know the moden
has sort of essentially an army of
Engineers they I would say they're a
successful startup because Ponder just
sold yesterday Ponder data is the
organization the the the company that
was built around modin they just sold
yesterday to uh snowflake so um so that
that exit is kind of over but the the
open source project is has been pretty
successful a lot of code contributions
into into moden but you will see a lot
of these issues saying hey I'm trying
this pandas operation it's running too
slow what is happening
right
um and then there are there aren't
really any good benchmarks for pandas
right now right so there are some
benchmarks that have very limited
coverage usually they use a single data
type maybe they they just create a data
frame full of integers and then they run
some typical uh operations that take
time to do so there's an evaluation only
of relational operations for these
systems right so the most famous one if
you kind of Google
data frame Benchmark uh you will get a
your top hit is going to be something
from h2o.ai which is a uh an
automatically running comparison of um
data frame engines for set queries right
so if you visit their website it it gets
updated I think automatically there's a
nice cool script that basically says run
this one operation over some synthetic
data and uh measure the time taken by
different data frame libraries right and
and uh it's called the database like Ops
Benchmark from uh
h2o.ai and notice that they only have
three different tasks with there one
group by one join and another type of
group by that was changed in 2014 for
some reason and then they have three
scaling factors which is five gig uh 0.5
gigs 5 gigs and 50 GP right um so again
this I would consider this also to be
very spe a very specific type of
Benchmark that is taking a specific
operation and then saying how does this
run over different query engines it's a
good start but we need uh more realistic
ways of benchmarking uh data frame
systems right so what I would like to
pait is the ability to generate a a
workload that is indicative of what
people typically do on uh pandas with
data frames right um so the first thing
I want to say is instead of just having
data frames that are filled with integer
values they need to have realistic data
types so you can have uh strings of
arbitrary length you could have uh a
wide variety uh in the types of data
that you represent in data frames right
so we want sort of realistic values I'm
not sure if that's necessarily visible
but you know we might have Fields like
country or maybe a large blob of text or
floats and things like that the second
thing I want to also mention is we want
to try to generate workflows that um
have different structures right so there
are different data analysis patterns
sometimes you might have a linear
pattern where you start with the data
frame and then you sort of modify it in
different ways in order for you to get a
certain um subset of that data frame
which we then may send to a machine
learning model for training uh those are
linear workflows but sometimes you might
have multiple uh machine learning
Engineers who are trying different
Feature Feature engineering uh ideas so
they might Branch their um data set into
multiple branching patterns or
somebody's working on some fresh data
and they throw a lot of Engineers at the
project and then you basically have a
star like um representation of what your
workflow is right like so multiple
people working on multiple samples of
the data for example so we want to try
to build a system where we are able to
do all of this right so the system that
I built as part of my PhD is called
called fuzzy data it's a workload
generation tool that is programmable and
allows you to sort of generate
automatically generate data frame
workflows right so the idea is you
should be able to take a typical data
frame workflow maybe you have two a
parket file and a CSV file that you've
decided to load and then you merge them
into a single data frame uh based on
some key and then maybe you do some kind
of row filtering followed by a pivot and
then you get a a data frame that is
useful for you to then pass on to a
machine learning um system right so
we've abstracted the notion of this by
calling this a a a fuzzy data workflow
and then we have abstractions for each
of these artifacts the fuzzy data
artifacts are just an abstract
representation of a table it contains
the metadata or the schema of the table
as well as serialization and
deserialization routines we also have
abstract representations of these common
operations that people like to do so
they're are both relational operations
as well as operations that you might do
in pandas currently it's a small subset
of operations but we would like to grow
this over time right pandas has hundreds
of different operations that you can do
on data frames so we want to have an
abstract representation of these
operations what how the arguments are
specified and then how we expect the
schema of the data frame to change when
we apply this operation so all of this
is abstracted into fuzzy data and what
we we can do now is we can give an
abstract specification of a workflow as
well as some input files and what fuzzy
data gives you now uh yeah and then we
also specify the workflow itself right
so a list of operations Source artifacts
and maybe enough information that allow
you to scale the data frames up and down
if if and when required once we have all
of this defined and we Define these in
Json files with a bunch of uh input
artifacts uh a Json file a set of
operations we can describe the entire
workflow
in a um Library agnostic manner what
fuzzy data can do is can take that Json
specification and those uh files and it
can generate the individual workflows
for each of these systems so using a
fuzzy data uh workflow specification you
could say hey generate a panda's
workflow and it'll actually generate the
python code for the Panda's workflow uh
it can generate the modin workflow where
it's basically the padas workflow but
the input was changed to modin but more
importantly it can also Al generate the
equivalent SQL expressions for this
workflow as long as these operations are
uh supported so right now this is what F
looks like right given some abstract
workflow specification we can generate
all of these different code for all of
these different systems and we can run
them and then we can kind of Time how
long it takes to finish executing the
workflow I'll kind of pause here for a
second because I talked quite a bit and
if anybody has sort of questions or
comments at this point can let me know
otherwise what I can do is I can I can
sort of keep going all right so so
that's what this project is essentially
right and the other thing that I'm
leveraging is the ability to generate
truly random data frames that have uh
realistic values and there's a very cool
library in Python called Faker Faker
allows you to generate any sort of like
fake data so you could ask it to to
generate fake names it'll actually
generate strings that are like first
name last name you can generate fake
ssns you can generate fake telephone
numbers and the best part about Faker is
you can set a local so you could say
maybe Hindi India and it'll generate
fake Hindi names fake Hindi locations
fake Hindi addresses it's a great tool
especially for those who are doing sort
of web testing and maybe form input
validation and they want to do
localization for different areas and
that's the main use of Faker right so
what what the ability the the the great
thing about Faker is I can tell it to
generate a a five table U data frame I
mean this is uh Faker doesn't generate
data frames uh fuzzy data does but Faker
will generate those individual values
inside so give me give me random um
dates uh formatted in ISO 8601 or give
me random cryptocurrency codes and then
Faker will just generate those and then
I can generate a whole data frame out of
it right so give me integers uh or give
me random numbers those are fairly easy
to generate but you know you can also
get random us
addresses uh hopefully I don't think
they're valid addresses but yeah and
then the idea now is I can now generate
these realistic data sets with varied
data types and I can vary between string
numeric daytime and Etc what fuzzy data
does is internally it keeps a taxonomy
of each of these column types to say
that some of these types are groupable
so I could do a group by operation on
some of these columns uh some of them
are are unique enough that I could use
them as a join key so I keep that
information so that I can generate a
whole set of operations that I want want
to use this with um in the future and
you know again part of this talk is to
see if people are interested and if they
would like to contribute to this project
some ideas that I was uh thinking about
is maybe generate data that has
functional dependencies so you generate
name SSN pairs so that if a name and SSN
appears it always appears in the same
sequence that's a database functional
dependency or if you want to enforce a
certain amount of cardinality you wanted
you want to generate a huge data frame
that has a billion rows and you are
about to do a group bu on one of the
columns so you want a fixed cardinality
maybe one billion collapses down to uh a
thousand rows so that's what I mean by
enforced cardinalities or in in some of
these
columns uh so the operations that uh I
encode in fuzzy data basically what I'm
doing is I I have the entire system
allows us to encode the operational
semantics and it basically is a way for
us to describe that if you need to do a
group by you need at least one groupable
column maybe one column on which you can
do some sort of aggregation and then
after the group by this is the expected
schema transformation that will happen
when you apply this we want to do this
in a in as broad of a manner as possible
so that you can finally generate the
code for those individual data frame
systems like like pandas and modin and
so on so forth
right
so but the actual implementation of this
operation is now left to the client
right so we want we we write we write
these clients for pandas for mod and for
sqlite what we do is we actually
implement this oper operation in those
clients
um and then finally a a workflow is
something that we can basic we can so
fuz data has the ability to generate
random absolutely random workflows or
you can provide a Json specification of
a workflow and what you can do now is
you can automatically use failor to
generate the actual code for the
individual libraries and all the
specifications are in Json so that makes
it human readable editable you can
encode your own workflow so if you'd
like to if if you're company is deciding
what data frame system I need to use
they can take a typical workflow encode
it using F data and then just run it
across different systems to kind of use
the inbuilt code generator to to see
what the difference is right um yeah all
right and then one sort of again
whenever I say future work this is me
putting my PhD hat on because this is
what I had to convince uh you know my um
sort of advisers and committee about
like these are the future directions but
these are also things that if people
find this tool useful there are there
are avenues for contribution right so
one thing that you know if if you're a
language expert or a python expert there
are there's a possibility of taking a
jupyter notebook and then automatically
extracting this workflow specification
out of it right using um basically
programming language uh PL uh sort of uh
things that you you can do in
programming language or uh inspecting
the abstract syntax tree and so on and
so
forth um so what our system does we
there's a little bit of math in this
slide but basically these are the
parameters that we can pass into fuzzy
data we can ask generate a workflow that
has 100 different artifacts for example
and the initial data frame that you
generate needs to have at least R rows
and uh C columns uh I have a way of
controlling the linearity of this
workflow by using something called a
branch Factor there's a some complex
math I had a math sorry a physics
roommate who came up with this really
neat way of saying how linear do you
want your workflow to be versus how uh
branched out you want your workflow to
be so we can plug in a number there and
we can basically generate any sort of
pattern of workflow that we want right
and um So currently we've I've written
three clients for fuzzy data there's a
panda's client uh and a modin client so
if my abstract data representation is
like I'm going from data frame one to
data frame two by sampling 100 rows then
my fuzzy data will automatically
generate the pandas code for that right
like df1 do sample n equals 100 but you
can take the same specification and you
can say generate the SQL for this and it
would say create view D2 as select star
from D1 order by random limit 100 right
so you can that's the SQL way of taking
a 100 uh samples from a table right
So So currently we all of these
operations are implemented in fuzzy data
right we can load data frames we can do
a select operation on some kind of
filter condition we can up we can create
a new column by applying some function
uh we can project a set of columns we
can sample rows we can join two data
frames based on a common key we can
pivot but you can only pivot in pandas
and mode in SQL SQL light for as for now
doesn't support pivot operations but you
could write write maybe a client for
mssql or some other commercial SQL
system that actually supports pivoting
operations you can also Group by uh you
can so some operations like fill they're
pretty common in pandas right like you
have a null value or a zero value and
you want to fill everything in the
column with something else and so on
right and um and basically these are all
the client operations that we support
right so the main thing that I'd like to
uh sort of pitch fuzzy data for uses if
you're currently writing a data frame
based system you can use this for fuzzy
correctness checking so this is
literally a random workflow generator
and you can use it to just run and
generate hundreds of artifacts and run
hundreds of operations and use it as a
way for testing whether your data frame
engine actually works or not right and
in fact that's kind of what we uh
used um fuzzy data for right so we used
it to uh basically run against sort of
the daily snapshots of modin and try to
find bugs that were introduced by
somebody changing the mod modin code
base we were able to find at least two
or three major bugs this was of as of
last year we found a bug in modin where
if you loaded a data frame from a disk
and then you appli two different group
buys this this was okay in modin but if
you generate a data frame in memory and
apply those group bu then that group buy
does not work in mod this was so an
issue that we surfaced and then got them
to fix through this uh
Tool uh so as a result of this and then
I reached out to them and I said hey
this is uh a problem you maybe you want
to look at this and then they promptly
issued a bug fix they got it fixed now
what has happened since then is fuzzy
data is now part of the continuous
integration Suite of modin right now so
um it's basically sitting and running
randomly generating data frames and for
every um every new release of of modin
there will be some tests that run using
fuzzy data to see if there are mistakes
right um the other great thing is like I
mentioned you can take a fuzzy data
encoded workflow and you can run it
across different systems and compare the
results to make sure that they're doing
the right thing and uh what you can do
is you can take an existing workflow and
code it into Json spec and then run it
over different systems and get a
performance uh result right so U Mod's
demo was a n n YC cab demo where they
take a huge uh NYC taxi data set and
then they Group by maybe I I don't
remember exactly what they did but they
Group by certain parameters maybe time
of day and things like that they run it
on pandas mod in using two different
backends in SQL light and this is one of
their main things that they wanted to
promote was how fast mod in is compared
to pandas and how fast it is well they
don't compare to SQL light but we are
able to because of fuzzy data right so
this looks like this is great great like
modin is like four times faster uh to
run this uh particular um uh scheme and
in fact this was used to validate their
claims as well right so they claimed it
this four times faster I took it into
fuzzy data generated all the code for
this ran it and we were able to sort of
verify that it was four times
faster um the other thing you could do
is you could take a workflow and then
scale all the artifacts up so you could
say this workflow has these data frames
that are maybe 100 rows let me scale
that up to million rows and see what
happens that's another thing that you
could do with fuzzy data so that's a
great way to sort of explore uh that uh
a workflow that worked on a sample of
the data should also work on a the
entire data or the entire data set and
you can verify whether it actually runs
and how much time it takes to to do this
this scaling right so what we did was I
generated a random workflow in fuzzy
data we started from some uh artifact
and then what we did was we basically
ran multiple sample operations and
multiple group buys multiple projection
operations so from starting from a basic
data set we we generated 11 different
data frames from it by running different
operations using a weir branching factor
and what I did was I took this very same
workflow and I scaled it from a th000
rows all the way to 5 million rows and
now you can sort of see how different
data frame engines are scaling uh uh and
this is a case where pandas beats modin
right modin was not optimized enough to
do fast random sampling in a distributed
fashion because of all of the sampling
operations that are happening here now
uh Mod's not doing so well right so
again this is another case where um uh
there are operations where Mod's not
fast and you know they admit it as well
right it's a work in progress they're
still working on this this is as of last
year I haven't had time to rerun this
Workforce so we'd have to see how things
go now the these days right uh fuzzy
data is completely open source it's
available on GitHub um you can pip
install and you can play around with
this so you could just say pip install
fuzzy data and then say create a pandas
workflow that has um you're starting
with a data frame that has 10,000 rows
and 20 columns and create 20 versions
like run random operations and create 20
different data frames from that uh one
that initial data frame and then you can
take that data frame that you generated
and then you could replay it on a
different client right so replay it on
modin and then see what this was right
so for those who are working on open
source projects especially if you're
working on these alone uh if you would
like to get your project to be pretty
popular so this is the fuzzy data
repository on GitHub and if you um if
you visit the PIP page it's it's now
like at 300,000 downloads right that is
not 300,000 organic downloads I don't
have 300,000 developers who are working
with this this is all from the mod in CI
pipeline so every time there's a new
version or a new nightly build of the
modin system it just pulls the latest
version of fuzzy data and runs it
against their code base but if you'd
like to get a high download count for
your project uh that's I think one of my
suggestions is is try to integrate it
into into a big project CI Pipeline and
you you'll get you won't get stars but
you will get like a lot of downloads for
your project if you wanted to um so yeah
there are a lot of things I wanted to do
with this project but again since I've
now sort of transitioned to full-time
teaching at you Chicago I I haven't
really gotten the time but some work
that's fairly easy to do is to write
additional clients for this right you
could try writing a polars client or a
Rapids client or a duck DB client right
duck DB is super popular now as a system
that uh does um sort of data frame um
data frame like it's they're trying to
be the SQL light for um analytics so uh
because they use an extremely fast query
engine and things like that right uh we
also talked about making more realistic
uh data frames like generating realistic
functional dependencies and so on so
forth right uh but that's you know I'm
I'm trying to reach out to more people
who use things like this so maybe it's
possible that at least it's in a it's in
a state where it's a it's a public
project on uh on piie and you can
basically just pip install and play
around with it for folks who are doing
any sort of research on data frames it's
it's possibly a good tool that you can
use to to try uh different things with
um with data frame engines like pandas
and so on and so forth right so yeah
basically what my um my the reason for
the stock is essentially to kind of
convince you that existing benchmarks
are not great anecdotal evidence is also
not great when you are in a decision um
role for your company or you're an
engineer for a company that is working
heavily with data frames and your CTO or
somebody comes to you and says what data
frame engine should we use because
pandas is not scaling fast enough um
you're going to see a lot of marketing
material from different uh companies and
then they may or may not necessarily be
true uh I won't claim that fuzzy data is
like the One-Stop solution where you
just go and you you can plop in a um uh
your workflow and try to get answers but
it's a step in that direction right we
want to try to make more industry
standard benchmarks for these kinds of
uh
systems and you know we we were able to
use it as a fuzzy correctness check and
at some point I would like to you know
maybe get the community around building
an actual data frame Benchmark right
encode some some more realistic
workflows and use it to compare
different data frame systems because
there's an explosion of these data frame
systems um thanks for coming to my talk
I'm soale right I'm available on soal
ran.com and uh yes please if you find
this uh interesting at all please visit
fuzzy data's GitHub page and uh you can
check out ways in which you can
contribute or try out the the project if
you're working with the sort of these
data frame systems right thank you very
much uh hopefully the talk was
accessible I kind of went in like a big
rant about data frames but if you guys
have any sort of questions or comments
about this stuff or any sort of
experiences that you guys have with
pandas you guys can let me know pandas
or any sort of dat frame engine for that
matter
oh
yes so it's a great work and I'm going
to give you a star on GitHub like after
going home
like in general right like when we build
machine learning pipelines on or
something the data pipeline that we
build at starting like matters a lot
right so with this F fuzzy data there is
a lot of scope that we can create
different kinds of pipelines so often we
like even somebody's doing a data
architecture like architecture solution
architecture so they go with like okay
we are getting this much amount of data
so we'll be using this pipeline to get
the model better like the efficiency or
like the scalability whatever so now
with the fuzzy data we can do multiple
iterations so there is the fake
generation part that we have and you are
creating dags like a different workflows
so we can always experiment more with
the fuz DAT and then yeah can build
better systems and now like if somebody
asks like this C or somewhere we can
show okay I have experimented enough so
this pipeline or the workflow is better
for our solution so it would be very
great great
[Music]
work yeah I mean the the intention
behind this work was this was auxiliary
work for other things that I was doing
in my PhD which was I was working on
something called lineage inference if
you have a bunch of these random CSV
files that are sitting in a data
repository is there a way you can
connect them with each other without
looking at the code right so one thing I
needed was the ability to generate very
randomized workflows and this fuzzy data
is something that came out of that
absolutely um yeah and just uh
yes like SPSS SAS or Excel access to
your F data yeah so that's another great
question right so what about things like
SPSS so one of the things we can do is
any any application that can export to
CSV file right you can use that as an
input into fuzzy data if you want to so
if you were working on an Excel
spreadsheet or possibly SPS I'm not
entirely sure about SPSS but if you're
working on an Excel spreadsheet you can
save it out as a as a CSV file and we
should be able to bring it into fuzzy
data and then we can basically ask it to
just try to randomly generate operations
if you want to right it's not it's not
super easy if you've not generated the
data using Faker but at least you can
give the specification a workflow
specification starting from that data
yeah it's independent it's independent
it's not supported necessarily by any
sort of like and the only integration it
is it has right now is it's part of mod
and CIP pipeline but it's it's yeah it's
not it it is it is installable right
it's available as a python package you
should be able to install it on pretty
much any machine if you want to try it
out so that's the current situation um
yeah any
other this whole thing is in Python it's
all
python everything's written in Python
right so yeah and then the SQL
generation is is just code generation
that's happening inside python itself
yeah yeah pretty much you can use it on
yeah any any sort of Linux environment
you should be able to pip install and
try it out right so it should it should
work all right if uh any other sort of
questions comments all right uh thanks
again for uh coming to the talk uh this
is fun nice to uh again reach out to
people in the Chicago community and and
online as well and um if anybody else
wants to say a few things or we could
just end there yeah
all right thank you
everyone